I'm with NIR again in your book you talk
about manipulation metrics could you
explain about that yeah so ethics is
something I care about deeply and a
question I often get is you know aren't
you teaching people how to make the bomb
right aren't you
giving people the tools to use our
deeper psychology to manipulate people's
day-to-day behaviors and the answer is
yes that in fact these tools can be used
for nefarious purposes and the reason I
wrote this book was because I worked in
the advertising and gaming industry and
I'm trying to bring these techniques
that advertisers and gamers have known
for quite some time but to bring these
techniques to the larger community to
help people build products and services
not just in gaming and advertising but
in in healthcare and in education in all
sorts of industries where we can use the
power of habits for good and so that's
really why I the first reason I wrote
this book but there's still this this
this test that I give to someone who's
concerned hey how do I make sure that
I'm using these habit-forming techniques
for good and so I provide this two-part
test in the form of what I call what you
mentioned the manipulation matrix the
manipulation matrix is this four
quadrant matrices where on one axis you
have do you believe that the product or
service that you're working on is
materially improving people's lives yes
or no that's the first criterion the
y-axis do you believe what you're
working on is materially improving
people's lives yes or no and only you
can answer this question right this
isn't a test for you to judge other
people or for other people to judge you
it's sincerely for this question of hey
how do I make sure that I'm using my
limited time on earth right how do I
allocate my human capital towards
something that can serve a higher
purpose that can do some good in the
world so that's the first question but
that's not good enough because there's
another question that I think is
critical which is am i the user am i the
user so there's this two-part test now
why do I make people answer that
question that's what's on the x-axis of
yes I'm the user or no I'm not the user
do you happen to know the first rule of
drug-dealing never use closed yeah never
get high on your own supply very good I
don't want to ask about your
background but let's just go with that
right that's the first rule of
drug-dealing never get high on your own
supply so what I'm doing by asking
makers to consider this question of
number one do I believe what I'm working
on is materially improving people's
lives and the number two and either user
I'm making them break that rule because
if there are any negative effects to
overusing this product right if this
product is potentially addictive as
opposed to just habit forming guess
who's gonna be the first person to
realize it so that two-part test I think
puts you not only in a good moral
position because you are the user of the
product interestingly enough it actually
increases your odds of success from a
business perspective you become what I
call a facilitator if you can answer in
the affirmative to these two questions
you're a facilitator and it turns out
that the companies that we talked about
earlier Facebook and Google and
Instagram and whatsapp and a slack and
snapchat all of these companies turns
out were started by facilitators doesn't
mean you can't make money or have a good
business in any of those other four
quadrants it's just that I think your
highest odds of success and you're also
in a good moral position if you can
answer yes to those two questions you
probably also feel very passionate if
you're the user right right right and
you just build better products right the
advantage of knowing your user right
because you've got the user right there
you've got your customer in you is a
huge advantage and we don't always have
that opportunity you know if you're
working at an agency or working in a
company where maybe it's servicing
somebody who's not you as the user we
don't always have that luxury
but then again we always do right we
could always choose what we work on and
what we're gonna spend our our time on
and so I think that's that's the best
place to be can you give us an example
of how you can hook use hooks for good
sure so I a reason why I wrote this book
is because I want people to use the
psychology of habits to help people live
better lives and so I actually do a bit
of angel investing when I see these
hooks in products that I think can
actually improve people's well-being so
there's several companies that come to
mind one company that I'm a big fan of
is called pantry labs and pantry labs is
trying to take on this obesity epidemic
and what the the company founders
realized is that
people were eating unhealthy food
because look let's face it unhealthy
food is very convenient it's cheap and
it's delicious right so how do we
compete with a vending machine full of
refined sugars that are bad for us we
though we know cause obesity na'kal all
kinds of other problems and that's the
entire vending machine so here comes
pantry labs and says look we're gonna
take a refrigerator with a door on it
and we're gonna attach like a kind of
like an iPad like device to the front
and you can open the the refrigerator
whenever you like but as soon as you
take something out of that machine that
happens to be stocked with fresh
delivered food every day the food is
delivered fresh it's full of salads full
of fresh ingredients that are that are
very nutritious and healthy for you as
soon as you take out the the food from
the machine it has an RFID chip attached
to it and your credit card is
automatically charged so now for the
first time healthy food in an office
building is as convenient to acquire as
unhealthy food and they're really
changing people's lives their day-to-day
habits it turns out that losing weight
doesn't have to be about willpower it's
not you know your lack of character that
you can't you know you can't resist
these temptations it's just that if we
make the behavior easier to do which is
a big part of what I described in the
book and the action phase of the hook if
we make that behavior easier to do and
we build a habit out of eating healthy
food by making it as accessible as
unhealthy food that's all we got to do
right we don't have to expend willpower
we don't have to do all this hard work
and that's really what's so beautiful
about using habits to change behaviors
that when we use habits we offload the
willpower it doesn't have to become a
struggle anymore it's something that we
do day in and day out with little or no
conscious thought so people will do the
right thing if you make it easier right
easier and make it a habit right so part
of what makes using pantry labs so easy
is I put in my credit card that's the
investment phase of the hook and then I
tell it my preferences and so more of
that food gets delivered to me in the
future so the this refrigerator that's
just a vending machine essentially gets
smarter and smarter over time the more I
use it